a representative from the
palestinian health ministry speaking now
let's have a listen
rescue and the assistance because gaza
strip
needs a lot of assistance also
in the field of electricity we need to
say that the
electricity companies is not
at all ready is not at all
able to reach the areas where we are
needed and damage has been there
in so many places in the gaza strip
and we need not citizens to be
killed or we need not our staff to be
killed so we have to work hard
and our teams everywhere
are trying as much as they can to help
the people needed and to
offer more electricity to the citizens
in houses in hospitals and everywhere we
reach a point
that we cannot repair
because our stocks are almost empty
we need a lot of things and we urge
everyone those who have some power
to allow the electricity company
to get
the necessary tools for maintenance
because
in these conditional circumstances we
suffer a
lot a lack and a big shortage
of cash so of course
our company and through some
efforts from the energy authority are
trying to sustain and maintain
the plant and we went
to get some petrol for their station
for the generation to work for two or
three days
maximum these amounts of
petrol are not enough at all because
we bought these amount of petrol from
the local market
probably if we have transportation
probably if we have
paved roads the mission will be
easy but because of the current
aggression against gaza strip
and the difficulty to move here and
there made it
very difficult for us to get what
we need we need to
continue the work of the generations
for few days maximum and
we warn everyone that
we might not be able to
buy more quantities
of petrol you have to know and everyone
has to know that
one generation might use 150 to 160
000 liters of water to get
20 or 25 megawatts so
this is not enough we cannot have enough
petrol
and we cannot be up to the level of
consumption
of the people and the hospitals and
we wish everyone we wish the
international community
we wish all the parties to respond
positively we also want to thank
those who are trying to help and to stop
this aggression against
gaza strip this is the statement of the
electricity
company and we wish everyone will
positively
respond
do you mean generation or distribution
there is a threat that these companies
might stop because karma muslim crossing
is is closed and it's expected
petrol is expected to come to an end
this evening there is a grant from qatar
and we are now trying to contact the
local market
to get as little as we can from
petrol there is enough for one two or
three days maximum
that's why we need solutions to be there
within the few coming days thank you
thank you very much i appreciate it
thank you very much
uh correction to what i said earlier
that he's actually from the gaza power
plant there and giving you a
something we need to remember as well
while we obviously focus on injuries and
deaths
a lot the level of destruction to
infrastructure
is huge as well and this is somewhat
they're talking about
shortages of fuel and water fuel to run
generators
as well and how even if they could get
things in it's difficult with the amount
of infrastructure and roading that has
been destroyed as well so that's just
something to keep in mind
as well that it is not just a human toll
there is
a lot of destruction to the
infrastructure there which is affecting
those who still
live in gaza